welcome in rotterdam
the president the prime minister and
minister of finance will first give a
statement and after that there's
room for a few questions prime minister
thank you so much and thank you all of
you for coming and
let's agree that we are meeting at a
very special place here today
the world port center at the heart of
the port of rotterdam
which is also the beating heart of the
dutch economy
this city's motto
not words but deeds is one that should
appeal to everyone in this room
and is precisely what today's meeting is
all about
turning our talk into action making
reforms and investments to enhance our
dutch economy
today i'm delighted we are delighted to
be marking the european commission's
positive assessment
of the netherlands recovery and
resilience plan
i'm very pleased ursula that you as
commission president are with us today
to bring us the good news at least i
hope you will bring us the good news
that was at least what we hoped for
this means our country will be able to
claim
4.4.7
billion euros of support from the
recovery and resilience facility
which was set up a couple of years ago
to help the eu deal with the economic
impact of the covert 19 pandemic and
also to emerge from this crisis stronger
and it comes not a moment too soon
because now we face countless new issues
issues we can best address by embracing
eu cooperation and solidarity
and that is why i believe it is so
crucial that the eu and its member
states have created the extensive next
generation eu package
as well as helping us absorb the impact
of the pandemic it will also enable us
moving forward to prepare for the big
issues that now lie ahead
for the netherlands it has always been
important that investment in sustainable
growth must go hand in hand with needed
reforms and sound economic
foundations and in the spirit of this
city's motto mr mayor our recovery and
resilience plan is turning words into
deeds
we are not only opting to modernize our
housing and labor markets
we are also committed to driving the
digital and energy transitions in this
country
and the latter is especially urgent
after all the war in ukraine has made
clear that we need to rapidly
and also drastically reduce our
dependence on fossil energy
this plan contributes directly to that
goal and the netherlands is eagerly
taking up this challenge
in short
we are not just mitigating the economic
damage inflicted in recent years
we are also working to build a resilient
digital and sustainable netherlands
i'd like to thank the european
commission for its can i say critical
appraisal during the plan's development
and thank you to ursula van der ley in
particular for being here today and
being so much a champion of this whole
process
i expect that in the years ahead mrs von
ley will keep us on our toes
as we work to make our ambitions a
reality
and i look very much forward to our
further cooperation to that end and i
would like now to give the floor to my
esteemed colleague the deputy prime
minister and minister of finance
and of course prime minister mark
i'm equally delighted that rumor has it
that the recovery and resilience plan
will receive a positive assessment from
the european commission
it's just a rumor
but the plan is of course a result of
close collaboration and i really also
like to thank all civil servants from
all the ministries that despite the
political obstacles i think we
coordinating and negotiating parties put
in their way by the delay they made up
for it in very good time and they put
forward a stellar plan so all praise to
all the civil servants that have managed
to meet
the deadline just in time and we also
worked very hard with a number of
stakeholders not only ministries but
also organizations civil society
organizations the business sector
and the plan is therefore a truly
national plan i believe of reform and
investment and as the prime minister has
said its aim is to really contribute to
a resilient sustainable and innovative
dutch economy those are three pillars
within our dna and we can fast forward
into the next generation of our economic
life the reforms are mentioned and the
investment choices of course and they're
really quite broad from housing to the
labor market and as we uh as we
referenced in the in the meeting we had
before
some of them were sort of 10 years
overdue
you might say sometimes we were plodding
through but ultimately we made it and
we're now ready to launch ourselves and
we're delighted that the commission has
also acknowledged this in a very
supportive way there is an investment of
course side and that reflects the
urgency to contribute to the green
transition which is not yesterday's news
or today it is urgent it's required and
actually is quite essential so 35
of the investment choices will
contribute also to the repower eu
objectives which actually were
recommendations that came whilst we
thought we had finalized but fortunately
thanks to the frank and super
constructive collaboration with the
commission we were able to integrate
them hence we are on par we are not
talking of the netherlands 2020 we're
talking of everything that applies to
the european commission's
country-specific recommendations for
2022
and so i'm grateful even though i didn't
necessarily say that to valdis at the
time when i spoke to him we're grateful
that you allowed us to integrate them so
we are
able to visit a number of projects that
that are relevant to the now ultimately
our ambitions are clear in an era of
geopolitical changes and an onset due to
the russian invasion of ukraine and the
geo-economic and financial consequences
i believe as we deliver as one we will
remain and become even more fit for
purpose as the prime minister has also
expressed
once once for also all our thanks to you
uh president van der lyon and all the
other commissioners and of course and
their staff for basically uh giving us
what we asked for
strict but fair
we thought this would apply to all other
member states but i think a moment of
humility is sometimes also in place it
was also applied to us as it should be
and it improved the end product and
ultimately if we can
transform if we innovate and if we can
manage the transition the experience of
the rrp will also really be one of
example that will enable the european
union to remain strong and even more
effective so thank you for that as well
another floor thank you so much
yeah thank you very much prime minister
dear mark uh deputy prime minister dear
sigrid thank you very much for having me
here
mayor thank you very much for having me
here in rotterdam
indeed um rotterdam is the home of
europe's biggest port biggest harbour
you said it is the heart of the dutch
economy well i would say as such with a
hard dutch economy it's also a
bellwether
for the health not only of the dutch
economy but also the european economy so
if the port is doing well our economy is
also doing well
and this port really is europe's gateway
for trade with the rest of the world
to be the gateway for trade with the
rest of the world you need the capacity
and you need to innovate and i know this
is very dear to your heart
so maratha dam is a model for both the
project we visited this afternoon
illustrates this perfectly i must say i
was fascinated to visit the alphanar
it's amazing to see that ship driven by
battery power
and demonstrating the zero emission
inland waterway project that has been
developed here
as we all know transport is one of um
the sectors where the carbon emissions
at the moment being are rising
um
going thus against the trend that we
have in all the other sectors that the
co2 emissions are decreasing so it's of
utmost importance that you innovate and
that we have solutions for example also
in the maritime transport and we all
know that maritime transport uses
normally heavy fuels that not only emit
but also pollute
therefore this project is more than
welcome
precisely because it will help tackle
the environmental challenges in a
coherent way it's clean
it's circular as we could see
and it helps obviously also stabilizing
the grit so a lot of good points in that
and therefore i hope that the alphana
will soon be joined by many many sister
ships that will chris cost the famous
canals you have here in the netherlands
without any emissions and pollutions
i think the alphanar is
typical for the type of project
we support with next generation eu
indeed we want to speed up the twin
transition the european green deal and
the digitalization
through intelligent investments and
through reforms
and thereby ensure abroad based economic
recovery initially
after the pandemic but now we also see
that it is more needed than ever
and the netherlands next generation eu
plan does just that you have a share of
almost 50 percent
devoted to climate measures to the
european green deal and 26 percent for
digital projects
that is by far overshooting the
requirements of next generation eu so
congratulations to that
the focus is on the development of
renewables particularly
both from the climate perspective and in
view of the need to get rid of the
russian fossil fuel dependency this is
of utmost importance now
the dutch plan devotes over 2 billion
euros in green investments it is coupled
with fiscal reforms to further
incentivize investments in this area
but the plan also has as we've seen a
strong focus on sustainable mobility for
maritime but also for rail and air
transport
and it includes the other dimensions of
the environmental protection for example
through an ambitious nature restoration
scheme
this is the green part almost 50 percent
of the planet much more is in it
but if we look at the digital side
the netherlands of course we know is
home to world champions like asml we've
visited it together amazing fascinating
and therefore of course the plan focuses
on boosting innovation through the
development of applications of quantum
technology
and
artificial intelligence solutions
beyond the climate and beyond the
digital priorities the dutch plan also
focuses on other challenges facing
society and the economy
this is notably the case for the housing
market
with almost 1.4 billion euros in
investment for the construction of
housing this is in fact the largest
component of the plan
and of course this aims to combine both
the environmental protection insulating
for example houses is the way to go
and of course also social fairness
the plan includes a series of reforms to
continue improving one of the
netherlands traditional strong points
that's your people and their skills
so a lot of investment in upskilling and
reskilling
and the plan includes reforms to
strengthen the public health sector the
pandemic preparedness we've learned our
lesson from the pandemic
and finally the plan addresses
aggressive tax planning and money
laundering two issues that are important
for the good functioning of our single
market
i could go on forever but i will stop
here
this is not the end of a journey it's
the beginning because of course now it's
about implementing but you were right
there is a rumor out there that we now
approve by giving you
the famous
yellow booklet
so congratulations
[Applause]
great thank you
i'd like to ask a question to the
president um this facility was uh the
idea behind this facility was to prepare
for next crisis after the cofit crisis
but we are already in the next uh crisis
the energy crisis is the european and
the dutch economy ready for this next
crisis
we all
have to
accelerate
what we agreed on in the european green
deal and fit for 55
indeed first of all because of climate
reasons we all have gone through a
summer with drought
and extreme weather phenomenons
but also because we absolutely have to
get rid of our dependency of russian
fossil fuels
and better even fossil fuels um overall
and therefore we have proposed with we
power eu that we accelerate the
investment in renewables
and you just heard the descriptions from
the prime minister and the deputy deputy
prime minister in topics where the
investment goes for example in hydrogen
but we were together also at the um
winch offshore wind summit
saw the plans to have a huge offshore
wind park
here
in the region in the north sea
if this wind park is in place it will
cover for example the energy consumption
of 50 million homes just to give a
perspective
of the potential that is in there so in
sum
we rediscover now
that renewables are not only good for
our climate and essential for our
climate but they are also a question of
getting independent of fossil fuels
independent of any kind of attempt to
blackmail us and that they improve our
security of energy supply
this mint
won't be here this winter already are
you worried about the financial future
near future for
the european people and the dutch people
important is that we stand together in
unity because together we are much
stronger than 27
and um
we have for example to fight the energy
crisis that is triggered by putin
manipulating the gas market we have done
a lot already the common storage we are
much better than we expected at 82 by
now we had expected to reach 80 end of
october that's good news
we have created a joint platform so to
diversify away from the russian fossil
fuels
and to look at other reliable suppliers
like the united states or norway for
example algeria who are stepping up
the energy supply to our continent and
now
we have on the table the proposal
to um tackle the challenge that we've
seen after summer of drought coming on
top for example hydropower being low the
waterways you know it being shallow so
the transport is not easy anymore
for for example coal we have put on the
table as a commission yesterday and on
paper a plan
how to move forward and how to address
that so if there's interest i could go
into detail but i think this might be
too long on the other hand if you look
at the financial financial situation for
investment that is necessary
the disbursement so far of next
generation eu overall an 800 billion
plan of price in prices of today
the disbursement has covered so far 100
billion so we still have 700 billion to
invest and this is now the time really
to bring it on the road
next question and pay
madam president as we've gathered here
there are serious concerns about the
health of queen elizabeth
what are your thoughts on this and what
does she mean to the european union
my thoughts and my prayers
are with her
and
she
is
she represents the whole history
of
the europe
that is our common home with our british
friends
she has given
to all of us in all these years
always
stability
confidence
she has shown an immense amount of
courage
she is a legend
in my eyes and therefore my prayers are
with her
[Applause]
madam president
is europe ready and strong enough to
confront mr putin who is threatening to
cut down the
the gas supply to the continent are we
strong enough also in the short run
because no one is doubting that we in
the long run will be able to replace the
gas but
in the short run we do have a very big
problem
i am deeply convinced that we will
prevail and that we are stronger
and if you look at the short run
as i said now norway is delivering much
more gas to the european union
than
russia
if we we have worked a lot and you see
it in two figures at the beginning of
the war
of all the imported gas 40 percent was
russian gas
this was since many years
today
only nine percent
are russian gas and this shows within
six to seven months how much
much we have been working
on getting rid of our dependency on
russian fossil fuels you know that we
have stopped the import of coal that we
are winding down
uh the import of russian oil
it's going to be tough
but we have created regional
groups to make sure that the gas flows
where it is needed
we have emergency plans
if you look at in the wider perspective
i'm deeply convinced that we will
prevail because this is not only
a war that russia has unleashed against
ukraine but this is a question whether
autocracies will prevail or democracy
will prevail and i'm deeply convinced
that we have the longer breath and on
the other hand
if you look our sanctions are more and
more biting and grinding into the
russian economy there's a very
interesting yale study i can only
recommend to look at it
that shows how deep the sanctions are
cutting and this is increasing week by
week that's the way we designed them
yes i know that for quite a long time
putin has been able to partially cushion
this
decrease
or the yeah of the
russian economy by revenues from fossil
fuels
and that's why it's so important that we
keep on track as i said the numbers are
telling that i just displayed yeah most
important of course is that most
important of course is that europe
remains solidare solidaria to one
another
do you trust that all countries will be
solidary yes i am convinced that this is
the case of course we always have to
discuss the details but
we have made a crucial experience
uh during the pandemic
at the very beginning there the member
states tried to go on their own
nationally
closing down borders export bans you
name it and then we realized this is too
big for each one of us
and then we stood together
and we
discovered the strength of sharing
and of solidarity
and as i said much much more than 27 we
are much stronger than 27 countries
together this is the european union
with all the power that is behind it and
if you look in hindsight this region
has gone pretty well through the
pandemic i'm very proud that we were the
only region worldwide that stayed open
for export of these life-saving vaccines
this has not been forgotten we take i
think we can take pride in that
and this experience of empowerment if we
stand together
this is still in our memory and now we
have the next crisis and it is a huge
crisis that we are going through
but if we stick together
with unity solidarity and determination
we will overcome
last question financial
thank you question for uh the prime
minister um yesterday and uh miss van
der lion uh put forward a proposal for
tackling the energy crisis and with one
of the most striking proposals being
putting a price cap on
energy prices and i was wondering what
the dutch position the division of the
dutch government is in that regard yes
that debate will take place tomorrow in
the energy council on celebrity
the state secretary will participate but
generally we are looking favorably at
the commission proposals of course we
have questions on particular proposals
and how to implement how to make sure
that there is enough flexibility
on implementation but generally we have
a favorable look at
the whole package
including
the idea
of
what they have done now in germany
in terms of
capping some of the prices and how could
we do that at the european level
we have again
taken a look at our position on a price
cap on
russian pipeline gas
we still have questions and worries but
we take a more positive view on those
proposals and again it will be debated
tomorrow and
then i get i think the commission will
reassess what comes out of the council
and um i hope the
the energy ministers can then as soon as
possible come to final conclusions
thank you very much
have a safe trip home
[Applause]